presenting a united front against a
president they say is illegitimate four
political parties are warning kai saeed
that he must backtrack on his decision
to seize executive power or they'll call
widespread protests against him
the president has taken everything he
has cancelled everything even the
institution for sorting out these
problems like fighting corruption all
these entities have been closed by the
president there's no parliament there's
no committee for overseeing laws there's
no government
[Applause]
demonstrations have already been held
against president saeed who last week
announced hit rule by decree and ignore
parts of the constitution that's after
he sacked the prime minister and
suspended parliament in july
on monday tunisia's foreign minister
told the un general assembly that the
president's actions are necessary for
the country's security that he was
acting with the will of the people
the dangerous situation threatening our
country and community is attributed to a
deeply rooted political polarization and
a socio-economic and health crisis this
is why the president of the republic had
to interfere and take a series of
exceptional resolutions and measures
based on our constitution to put the
country back on the right path towards
democracy
the largest political party in akhtar
says the president should call elections
to prove he has a mandate enacted isn't
in the newly formed coalition but has
spoken out strongly against his measures
describing them as a coup
why should one person
says that he can embody
the will of the people
so if he is with with the will of the
people if he is expressing the will of
people he has the authority to call for
elections and let the people decide
local and international human rights
groups have condemned saeed's actions
warning of a slide towards
authoritarianism
while the developments in july were
broadly popular two months on people are
growing frustrated by what they see as a
lack of progress or a plan for reform
analysts say that could work in the new
coalition's favor
with the deep economic crisis that we
are going to see the effects
of it in the upcoming weeks and months
they could seize maybe the opportunity
to show that unfortunately even by a
power grab even by uh uh
gathering all the powers president side
is unable to fight the real crisis of
the tunisians that are social problems
economy etc
with an economy on the verge of collapse
many say without political action the
situation can only get worse
alexi o'brien al jazeera
let's speak to our correspondent bernie
smith who's in tunis joins us now is it
ben what more do we know about this
coalition
nick there are four main parties in this
uh coalition you can sort of refer to
them as progressive and democratic style
parties one of them the democratic
stream
had initially been supportive of what
president kai said had done this party
the democratic screen had been very
critical of anada but now
they are pushing back
now they're saying that they uh want the
president to
appoint a government he hasn't yet done
that he hasn't articulated any uh
comprehensive economic policy or how the
government's going to finance the debt
none of these questions have still been
answered two months after uh
president kaisei seized power these
parties are saying that they're still
open for discussion
though and at the same time today we've
also had a statement from a lot of civil
society organizations very significant
groups in in tunisia and they're also
warning the president of the danger of
going too far in taking over power
without saying how long he would hold on
to the reigns of power and that these
civil society groups they've been
particularly critical of how the
president doesn't seem to have held to
account any of those people accused of
corruption that's been one of the big
complaints here in tunisia is a very
powerful corrupt people and they say the
president still has not done anything
about them
do is it possible to gauge the degree of
support that kais saeed has
not
easily no there were protests
in support of him a few days ago over
the weekend when there were other
protests
against what he's done there are other
protests planned possibly for this
weekend on sunday for people supporting
him as well
so you can
there was a there was a belief
when he took over the reigns of power
when he suspended parliament two months
ago
there seemed to be a general opinion
that people were very frustrated with
the democratically elected parliament
very frustrated with nothing being done
the economy was in a lot of trouble
and that had been exacerbated by the
pandemic and so there was people felt
that something needed to be done and
that is why it seems over the past two
months
the president has been given time
uh by these civil society groups and by
these political parties to offer some
sort of solution to the crisis tunisia
faces it finds itself in but so far the
president hasn't done that and this is
why people's patience seems to be
beginning to run out
all right burner thanks for that uh
bernard smith there in tunis
let's speak now to fadil alireza who's
the editor-in-chief of michikal which is
a tunisian news and analyst analysis
website joins us from tunis
also fadil first of all bernie was
saying our correspondent there was
saying that uh the president has been
given time but now opposition parties
are running out of patience is that how
you see it
certainly that's true um we saw um not
only immediately the the main governing
parties that were um saw them themselves
lose power when he first parliament on
july 25th opposing the president's moves
um we actually have seen uh other
parties as well that initially were
maybe on the fence that were sort of
tepidly um uh
or maybe skeptically uh supportive of
the july 25th move turn against him uh
and they're starting to coordinate with
one another
more importantly they're actually
coordinating with um as the
correspondent just mentioned uh civil
society groups particularly uh the ugtts
it's the main labor union which counts
uh about a million members out of an 11
million population they're very
important uh in especially the
bureaucracy uh within the uh space
institutions um they are uh expressing
more and more their displeasure with the
fact uh that they are being uh left out
of any sort of discussion about where
tunisia goes in the future they're
seeing this consolidation of the powers
of the presidency particularly with his
his new decree uh 117 a new presidential
order that uh suspended parts of the
uh constitution
on september 26th and second uh and
they're looking at this and they're
saying you know the fact that we're not
being uh consulted the fact that there's
a very small group of people just around
the president who are being consulted uh
really is is a problem for them so they
they say that kai saeed has lost his
legitimacy so this coalition how much
could it
alter the game board if you like how
much could it alter the state of play
i i think as time goes on there'll be
more and more pressure on the president
uh particularly as he has been very slow
to communicate uh his plans
on top of that we've seen um increasing
our sort of uh uh
will of people to go out in the streets
and oppose him the first demonstration
against them uh just a couple weeks ago
only had about 300 people but the one on
sunday saw closing to about 3 000 people
uh these may continue to grow larger
there may be more oppositions in the
streets but again there may be even
opposition um from these key um
political uh groups whether they're
political parties or the union or other
civil society groups um these are these
are institutions that have quite a lot
of uh influence quite an ability to to
really uh stop the president from from
moving forward on many issues you can
also see the business community as
working together alongside it's not
often that you see uh the union of
workers working together with the
business community represented by the
main chamber of commerce the utica so
the fact that there's these groups uh
sort of co-electing together and seeing
that they'd like to see some answers
from the president suggest that he's
going to have a difficult time going
forward with his plans if he continues
to go alone
it's a question i asked him bernard the
correspondent ben smith
is it possible to gauge do you think the
degree of support that the president has
and clearly he had support at the
beginning but
as we said people are running out of
patience can you can you gauge that can
you tell how many people what kind of
division in percentage terms there is
it's very difficult we saw early polling
at the very uh beginning stages that
showed a widespread support for the
president certainly when he made a
decision uh you know people went into
the streets across the country on mass
you know at night breaking curfew um
since then we've seen that uh um seem to
deteriorate certainly some of his
supporters have become a little bit less
vociferous on social media we've also
seen sort of counter protesters these
last two demonstrations against the
president um
getting smaller in number um but we'll
see you know there's also always a
possibility that the president will be
able to mobilize his supporters
particularly if he um finds a particular
issue that he can use to mobilize them
uh in the past he's really um focused on
anti-corruption issues as the
correspondent uh mentioned earlier um we
haven't seen quite a lot tangible in
terms of his anti-corruption efforts um
if he doesn't produce uh soon that may
also eat into his support among his base
right interesting thanks very much
indeed for that uh editor-in-chief of
mexico joining us from tunis thanks a
lot